hi there steve kaufman here today to
talk about language learning again of
course
and to talk specifically about managing
your time time management
now
if you enjoy these videos please
subscribe and if you like the video give
me a thumbs up if you want
um first of all why do i even do these
videos you know or why do i spend so
much time on language learning
it's because i like doing it i enjoy
learning languages it gives me a lot it
fills my life with
things that are interesting to me
i could be doing other things who knows
why we
devote ourselves to
this or that activity
it's important though to think that what
we are doing is worthwhile then we
derive satisfaction from doing it and
that's certainly my approach to language
learning i enjoy doing it i enjoy
sharing my enthusiasm with others
and sharing my experience with others i
probably spend more time on language
learning than most people
so to that extent what i do may be a
valuable
point of reference for others
so
managing our time so i'm going to talk
about three points actually
obviously right now where i'm committing
myself
to learning three languages
every day
arabic persian and turkish
time management becomes an issue
otherwise i'll just do one of these
languages and run out of time to do the
others
or won't find enough time to put any
significant amount of time in any of
them
so the first thing i've done is to make
sure that i have some very specific
concrete goals not a general goal like i
want to speak three languages
but rather specific goals the number one
goal i've set for myself is to create a
hundred links every day in each language
that means
creating links people ask what does that
mean if you go to
my website the one that i use that i've
co-founded with my son
lingq.com
you will see that the act of looking up
a word that we have not seen before
which is highlighted in blue on the
system that that is called creating a
link you then see
a number of possible meanings for that
word it's then saved to your database
and a number of
functions and and assists to learning
that word and learning the language are
activated on the website i did that the
other day i uh dropped my remote control
for the uh shouldn't leave it in my lap
so
concrete goals goal number one for me is
create a hundred links in each language
that means that once i reach 100 i go to
the next language so once i've gone
through all three languages at least
i've covered that so that's a concrete
goal
the other goals are the goals that i
think drive language learning for me are
creating links
which me that means you're forcing
yourself into new material you're
discovering new material you're not just
staying with things that are easy and
familiar because to find blue words
words you haven't seen before you have
to move forward into
material you haven't read before
the second thing is the overall number
of words you read is an important
counter so i do watch it
the the sort of linking activity
creating these links drives me but i
want to make sure that
i read
material where i've perhaps already gone
through and created the links but i'll
read them again
and the third major driver of my
language learning is listening but the
listening is is much easier because i
listen
whenever i can i don't deliberately sit
down to listen so i listen while doing
the dishes i listen in the car i listen
while exercising i listen on the bicycle
and
i listen now of course since i'm now
doing three languages if i look at my
statistics
i find that
my reading number if i look over the
last month let's say
looking at my statistics in link and you
can go to your profile and you see the
sort of
you know last week last two weeks last
month last three months whatever you
want to look at you'll see what you've
what your level of activity has been
and i see that my number of links is off
the charts because nobody is creating
300 links a day like i am so that i'm
well beyond the sort of targets that
link assigns
on my reading i'm more or less keeping
up to my target in each language that
means i'm reading a lot combined but of
course in each
spec you know individual language i'm
more or less keeping up to
the uh
the targets that link so about 15 000
words in each of those languages when it
comes to the listening i'm doing less
listening than is recommended because
i'm dividing my listening up between the
three languages and the listening is
usually just
the dead time when i have when i'm doing
something else and therefore i listen
so i have those goals the driving goal
is to create links but i do follow my
reading number and my listening number
the rest will take care of them
themselves like converting links to
known
known words all of that will naturally
increase as i continue listening linking
listening and reading
because as i come across words that i've
linked before that i see for the third
fourth fifth eighth time eventually i
moved them to no
so those are the goals so that's point
number one in terms of time management
point number two
be prepared to experiment find
you know which way of learning which way
of using your time works best for you
for example when i started i would just
think of making sure that i save 100
links every day and then i'd find that
it would be 10 30 at night and i'd look
up my statistics and i'll only add 50
links in turkish or in arabic so then i
have to sit there at 10 30 at night and
go through material which i don't really
like to do because i like to before
going to bed i'll read a book in english
on something
i don't necessarily want to be under the
gun to create 100 links at 10 30 at
night
so what i've now decided to do is the
first thing in the morning i create my
hundred links in each language i have
also decided that i am going to go
through wherever i find material that
has a lot of
unknown words
i go through and i just link the blue
words i don't read the words in between
because it takes too long especially in
arabic and persian where i'm reading in
the arabic script which
i'm not very good at so it's very goes
very slowly turkish is a lot faster
because it's written in the latin
alphabet so i go through there
before my wife gets up i've gone through
and i've knocked off a hundred links
created in each of three languages now i
can relax so i've got that behind me
now that's something that i just started
doing a week ago we'll see how that goes
but so far i'm enjoying it i think
that's a good way to go
then
after that i find time to read
and when i read typically i'm going to
find yellow words previously saved links
where i now know those words
but i'm not setting myself a target
i'm just when i come across them
i move them to known or i move them from
status 1 to status 2 or status three
and and by the same token when i
complete re-reading
a lesson i make sure
uh you know if this is the you know
again it's explaining how link works but
if i go through a lesson just linking
then
the system thinks i've read that lesson
so if i read it a second time
i don't manually add
reading
however if i read it a third time i
might manually add the reading number
although the manually added reading
number is not counted in your activity
index
something to think of so in a way i'm
cheating because when i go through
they're creating those links the system
thinks i've read that article or that
lesson but i haven't but then i make a
point of going back
to read again
listen and read
to make sure i go over that material
properly and read it because reading is
very important
so i experiment now it may be in two
weeks that i find that there's some
other combination of these activities
that works better for me but right now
i'm enjoying it because i find that even
going through and linking a bunch of new
words it is exposure to these words at
some level and then when i go back in
later on i pick up on i've kind of gone
over the same material a second time
this time through going through every
word whereas before i was just jumping
word to word and of course a lot of this
material is for example podcasts that
i've downloaded so then i listen to
these so i'm going over
sort of the same material
in different ways
understanding parts of it each time
but i do sense definitely that i hear
the three languages more clearly i am
making more sense of these three
languages so so far i feel this is
working and that brings me to the third
element of managing your time
so first of all set yourself goals
be don't be
afraid to experiment and to vary your
activities but third of all
whatever you're doing
try to enjoy it and try to believe that
what you are doing is worthwhile i
believe that what i am now doing is
worthwhile that it is working that i am
improving that i understand these
podcasts when i listen to them much
better than i did before that's my
impression i feel good about what i'm
doing i don't wish i were doing
something else i don't wish that i were
i don't know
reviewing words in a anki deck or
whatever however if you like reviewing
words in an anki deck
make sure you enjoy doing that and that
you believe that that is worthwhile
doing so you know managing your time a
part of that is also
to feel that whatever activity you're
committed to doing or whatever method of
learning you use
you think that's a good use of your time
you feel happy about what you're doing i
think that's an important an important
element of managing your time sort of
staying in the moment and thinking that
this is where i want to be and this is
what i want to be doing so there you
have it that's my little
spiel with reference to my own
experience on managing your time as a
language learner again if you would like
to receive my 10 emails on 10 tips on
language learning please click on the
button here on the screen
and i look forward to your comments bye
for now